a la espera de un nuevo lanzamiento
luego de varios intentos fallidos la
NASA planea enviar al espacio su misión
no tripulada artemis 1 este miércoles 16
de noviembre la cual no había podido ser
lanzada por problemas técnicos y
meteorológicos
artemis está utilizando una serie de
nuevos cohetes vehículos espaciales
transporte infraestructura y ciencia que
se realizarán en El Siglo 21
se trata de poner pasos en el sistema
solar para ser exploradores permanentes
no solo de la luna sino también los
asteroides Marte y eventualmente más
allá
artemis 1 será la primera de una serie
de misiones que planea devolver a los
astronautas a la superficie de la luna a
partir de 2025 y aumentar su presencia
en el espacio la misión durará 25 días
11 horas y 36 minutos y planea regresar
a la tierra el 11 de diciembre luego
recorrer aproximadamente 2.1 millones de
kilómetros con una ventana de 2 horas
para su lanzamiento se espera que el
cohete de 32 pisos de altura despegue de
cabo Cañaveral Florida Mientras tanto
aficionados esperan ver el lanzamiento a
unos kilómetros del centro espacial
Kennedy estoy feliz de que hayan vuelto
a poner en marcha el programa Ahora
estoy feliz de que la gente pueda venir
y disfrutarlo con nosotros Entonces creo
que es genial espero que todos los demás
vengan y traten de disfrutar como lo
conocemos según los pronósticos
meteorológicos artemis 1 tiene un 90% de
condiciones favorables para su despegue
la cual se convertiría en la primera
misión en llevar a los humanos de nuevo
a la luna tras 50 años